hello and welcome to still playing soup
team sip tea nope no name oops come on
losing time here with looking up the
name yeah the london system pretty
popular nowadays for no apparent reason
ok so let's go here and build up the
good old hedgehog one advantage of the
Hedgehog is you can make many moves in
short in a short period of time
always try it try to threaten checkmate
you never know you never know what might
happen yeah I'm trying for 55 even
though nampa should be five is not a
move that feels particularly pointed
maybe yeah I wanted to play Queen to be
seven but I'm just blundering stuff so
going back these six was hanging then
yeah one danger of this position is that
white is quite often just shuffling
around with and it's not quite clear but
it's just completely aimless shuffling
or if there are some point to to the
moose and this is sometimes an issue in
blitz chess and you okay this is not
shuffling he does he doesn't try for
thumb for something him pushing the G
porn okie dokie um night will come to
you for very likely let's do this
preparing on preventing the g porn from
from coming up Jim Knight f6 treats the
notes i'm not sure if that is good
though i don't want to spend much time
on this check
doesn't help young Bishop c6 blunder
stuff could play e5 but then I'm not
sure about if it helps just be an
annoyance if you trade so I'm happy with
that I think this helps makes it easier
for me to play be five
he wants to I don't get it going to 65
our probably can also go here though I
don't think there's something on the H
file him of course he goes for that the
moment I stayed there is that I don't
think there is something it is played
him absolutely sure
yeah maybe it's just a doubling huh 27
green edge for h6 Bishop f4 word
something like this
now aged six the danger is that you
might just take it this is the problem
okay I'm trying to try a different kind
of Defense takes and g5 try to try to
kill as bishop
just try to say that this is more
important than my week in position takes
I will go g5 so just go here and that
runs into the tempo that's pretty awful
or did I do that okay at least now I'm
basically forcing this no I'm not okay
but now i can take care right and just
be material up basically let's no no
dangerous attack any more I think Luke
h1 there's also III just blasting and
everything open yeah you have to go back
there I insist
rogue age 8 coming
hmm my bishop should should come come
over that would help quite a bit time
warning and you might take on air I
cannot take one dat
bootup f-86 stuff point and it's not
reacting to that
and I would for the counter take him
check check ah let's have a look first I
cannot enter them I don't see don't see
a direct win check check looks good
though opening up the G file for Luke g7
King f5 stuff let us strong
check I don't believe this nonsense he
tricked me hear it he treated him check
check check chera black forfeit what no
I forbid it on time I come on what is
what a nonsensical end of this game he
could ah it's half Jeff first maids and
everything and here i can take see her
unbelievable I'm eight seconds up and
he's totally busted let's just downright
terrible yeah Queen d1 whatever
everything wins even though even the
ending is a total win unbelievable how
can I lose this damn game ah yeah two
wins everything winds here and this is a
draw but I lose on time check check by
pressing the draw button here which
which was a draw I just I just cannot
press it anymore because I while
pressing I lose on time jaron can you do
the reason why I'm really angry is not
because I'm an idiot yeah I am but it
was a really nice game before I mean I
defended this quite well on the H file
and was making very nice progress Bishop
over 26 it was a really good game check
and he was just basically yeah hanging
in there in a completely lost position
check and then you screw that up yeah
this is this is the reason why I don't
get higher than this
rating or two for something I don't win
those those those games that are plus a
million yeah thanks for watching